[Music]
this laser weapon can strike targets
such as drones rockets and mortars and
can do so for a fraction of the price of
other missile power defense systems
the iron beam is an experimental project
built by israel it could be used in
conjunction with the iron dome which
launches rockets and is considered one
of the most advanced air defense systems
in the world
israel says the iron beam could enhance
its protection against threats from
iran's allies in lebanon and gaza
but some defense experts say the
technology has several weaknesses
including its short range
to perfect the system israel is in talks
with the u.s about cooperating on the
technology
here's how the laser beam system works
and why some military analysts say
american expertise could enhance it
the iron beam is composed of a laser gun
located on this swiveling unit a
surveillance system that tracks incoming
threats and a command center where
operators give directions
israeli officials say the laser gun fire
is a beam that uses 100 kilowatts of
power that's around 100 times the
typical electrical power that a
household in the u.s uses
here's what it looks like in action this
footage from the israeli defense
ministry shows the laser striking down a
rocket
israel's goal is to integrate this
weapon into its arsenal and also save
some money that's according to military
analysts who say the laser would allow
the country's army to reduce its
reliance on the more expensive iron dome
one interceptor missile fired from the
iron dome can cost fifty thousand
dollars or more in contrast israeli's
departing prime minister naftali bennett
said the iron beam could do the same
thing for as little as two dollars i
said there are two advantages one the
cost per kill the recurrence is low and
the second is that there is no
ammunition you save all this
train of production and logistics
that's uzi rubin a defense engineer and
military analyst years ago he developed
earlier defense systems for israel he
says the iron beam despite all its
advantages has a lot of issues to
overcome this is not a single bullet
does it sound to the disadvantage one is
a short range the other is
the sensitivity to weather and the third
is the low kiloway
let's start with the weather the issue
is that the system sensors can be
hampered in rainy and cloudy conditions
that means the iron b may not be
operational in israel in colder months
such as november and december according
to ruben
if the weather prevents it from working
israel's defense ministry says the iron
dome could kick in
another vulnerability is said to be the
range the beam loses power as it travels
through the air making its impact on the
target less powerful it's known as the
bloom effect when it hits the air
it starts blooming the the beam widens
up after a while it's so diluted it
doesn't have an effect
and then there's the speed at which it
can take down objects the period of
dwell time before the laser damages its
target makes it slower than the iron
dome when you push the button your beam
touches the rocket at the speed of light
but then it have to keep pumping energy
into the pocket until it melts or
exhaust something
that process could take a few seconds
and hamper its ability to combat
multiple incoming rockets ruben says
on its own the system could struggle to
counter strike similar to those seen in
this video footage where rockets are
fired from position in gaza city towards
israel in may of 2021.
still israeli officials said the iron
beam could be deployed early next year
israel's project comes amid a global
wave of interest in laser-powered
weapons
countries such as the us russia and
china all claim to work on the
technology which some defense experts
say could be a key component in future
warfare the pentagon is working with
major defense contractors and testing
advanced systems based on similar
technology to israel and some us tools
are estimated to be capable of firing a
300 kilowatt laser which is more
powerful than the iron beams the more
kilowatts of power the system has the
farther the laser can strike targets
although laser makers in the u.s and
israel told wsj that the range of laser
weapons can vary widely also depending
on the type of target
the iron beam is designed to detect
small targets up to 12.4 miles away
according to israel
analyst uzi rubin estimated that
american lasers could strike twice as
far as israel's that's still much lower
than the iron dome which can hit rockets
at a distance of up to 43 miles
the range is limited it's more limited
than the range of the interceptor
even a short-range interceptor weapon
because of all those limitations
security analysts say israel is seeking
support from the u.s to enhance the
weapon
president biden was showcased the iron
beam during a state visit to israel and
signaled u.s support for the tool
we have reaffirmed the unshakeable
commitment of the united states to
israel's security
including partnering with israel on the
most cutting-edge defense systems in the
world
including the u.s support for the iron
dome
and israel's new
laser-enabled system
called the iron beam congress is moving
ahead with plans to send israel another
one billion dollars to the iron dome
which the us army has also been testing
in some military bases
now any new cooperation on the iron beam
could accelerate the process of making
laser weapons a reality on the
battlefield
[Music]